hey this is preshtal Walker
here's a list of numbers
1 2 2 3 3
444 and so on up to 200 200. 200.
in this list the integer n appears n
times for one less than or equal to n
less than or equal to two hundred
the question is what is the median of
the numbers in the list
this is a no calculator question
I think the papria for the suggestion
and this comes from the 2021 AMC 12a
problem 16 and the AMC is one of the
Olympiad qualifying tests in America
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so to get started let's count the total
number of numbers in the list
we can do that by counting the number of
ones plus the number of twos plus the
number of Threes all the way up to the
number of two hundreds
so the number of ones is one the number
of twos is two the number of Threes is
three and so on up to two hundred
so we want the sum of the numbers going
from one to two hundred so we use the
famous formula and we have 200
multiplied by 201 divided by two and
that works out to be twenty thousand one
hundred
now similarly we can calculate the
numbers that are up to the last
appearance of the number K we count the
number of ones the number of twos the
number of Threes all the way up to the
number K so this will be one plus two
plus three all the way up to K and that
is equal to K multiplied by K plus one
all over two
so where do we go from here
we want the median now the list is
already in descending order
so that's good
the halfway point will be the total
number twenty thousand one hundred
divided by two
so the median will be any number between
the terms because the total number of
numbers in the list is an even number we
need to take any number between these
two terms
so we want the numbers up to n minus 1
to be less than or equal to twenty
thousand one hundred divided by two
Which is less than or equal to the
numbers up to n
so we can write this using the formula n
minus 1 multiplied by n divided by 2 and
that's got to be less than or equal to
20 100 divided by 2 Which is less than
or equal to n multiplied by n plus 1 all
over 2. so how can we work out this
inequality
well let's take a look at the numerators
we have n minus 1 multiplied by n and
this numerator is twenty thousand one
hundred so we need N squared to
approximately be equal to twenty
thousand one hundred now this is a no
calculator question so we need to
estimate this
so the square root of twenty thousand
one hundred is approximately equal to
the square root of two multiplied by ten
thousand the square root of ten thousand
is one hundred so this is one hundred
multiplied by root two root 2 is
approximately equal to 1.41 so this is
approximately equal to 141.
so this gives us one candidate let's try
n is equal to 141.
so we'll calculate 141 multiplied by
142.
in that case we have 141 squared plus
141 is equal to 140 plus 1. so we Square
this and we get 140 squared plus 2
multiplied by 140 plus 1 squared plus
this equals 19600 plus 280 plus 1 plus
141 which all works out to be twenty
thousand twenty two
but this is smaller than the numerator
of twenty thousand one hundred
so if we take all the numbers going up
to 141 it's still too little we haven't
reached the median value yet
so we are going to need the next number
which is 142.
so for 142 we can write 142 multiplied
by 143 we write this as 142 multiplied
by 141 Plus 2. 141 multiplied by 142
we've already calculated so we just need
to add 2 multiplied by 142. so we have
20 022 plus 284 which equals 20
306 and that is greater than the
numerator of twenty thousand one hundred
so this is what we want so just to put
it in another way we've calculated these
values and we're looking for a number so
that we could figure out the median
which will be between the 10 000 and
50th term and ten thousand and fifty
first term
so if we divide these by two we figure
out the numbers going up to 141 and 142
. so the numbers going up to 142 is 10
153 and the numbers going up to 141 is
10 000 and 11.
so we can see that 142 is the 10 000 and
50th value and ten thousand and fifty
first value in the list
therefore 142 is the median
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign